last Thursday feminist writer and
podcaster Megan Murphy tweeted her
observation that men aren't women
Twitter promptly suspended Murphy for
hate speech as somebody who's been
banned from Twitter for making
completely innocuous statements before I
feel for Murphy she is now experiencing
as a leftist the same targeting and
censorship that big tech companies
inflict on conservatives on a daily
basis but I cannot help but feel just a
teeny tiny supremely satisfying tinge of
schadenfreude as the left's ideological
chickens come home to roost the problem
is clear the left can have
transgenderism or feminism but it can't
have both Murphy correctly observes that
trans gender ideology which believes
that gender is fluid and socially
constructed undermines feminism which
advocates the advancement of women a
real and essential gender category what
Murphy doesn't seem to understand
however is that the root of this new
censorious anti woman ideology of
transgenderism lies in feminism itself
first wave feminists of the 18th and
19th century women like Mary
Wollstonecraft and Elizabeth Cady
Stanton acknowledged and celebrated the
differences between the sexes both of
them were married Elizabeth Cady Stanton
actually was married to the co-founder
of the Republican Party just a little
aside they didn't hate men they didn't
hate the natural differences between men
and women
by the 1960s however radical feminists
of the second wave women like Shula myth
Firestone rejected the complementarity
of the sexes Shulman Firestone called
the love between men and women the
single greatest impediment to women's
liberation and she sought to deconstruct
gender categories all together in this
very extreme view sexual difference
necessarily impedes equality therefore
no distinction between men and women may
be tolerated now 50 years later it's
that very premise that threatens to
destroy the feminist ideology that begot
it all together the left can have
transgenderism or it can have feminism
it cannot have both either men cannot be
women or there is no such thing as a
woman either men and women are distinct
categories or to quote plan
parenthood back in March some men have a
uterus if some men have a uterus that is
to say if some men are women then what
exactly is a woman if the sexes are the
same or they're only superficially
different they're only different in a
trivial way then why do we have
different words man and woman to
describe the same thing further if
there's no categorical distinction
between man and woman that is to say if
there is no real difference between the
sexes
then what precisely is feminism
shouldn't we just have humanism or
mankind ISM the very word feminism
demands that there be a difference
between men and women even the targeting
and the censorship that Murphy is now
experiencing finds its roots in the
second wave of the feminist movement
those radicals of the 60s and 70s
adopted the slogan the personal is the
political this comes from the title of
an essay by feminist writer Carole
Hanish the personal is the political
that means that the private is the
political there's no difference between
our private lives and our public
obligations but that distinction however
between the public and the private is
essential to our liberal society the
erosion of that distinction has course
into the character of political activism
and it's encouraged a politics of
animosity and personal destruction the
trouble for the left now is that it's
set leftism on a course of radical
subjectivism that prioritizes feeling
over fact your truth over my truth over
the truth it even justifies the
censorship of opinions by redefining
speech as violence which has led us to
justify the censorship of triggering
unsafe hateful language as a violent act
Megan Murphy is absolutely right to
acknowledge that men are not women and
she's right to fear the consequences of
a politics that is so personal
conservatives have long known these
simple truths
now the leftist feminists such as Murphy
faced a difficult choice do they align
servants who support free speech and
admit facts don't care about your
feelings or do they persist with a left
that would annihilate feminism
altogether
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
a lot to get to one of the most
interesting questions facing leftist
ideology right now plus we got to talk
about the real story of Thanksgiving but
first let's make a little money honey
and this is such a fitting sponsor for
the day before Thanksgiving blue apron
oh we're all looking forward to food
tomorrow we're all looking forward to
that one day a year when we can
guarantee that we're gonna eat good food
but you can guarantee that every single
day blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes to
your door blue aprons mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients
building a community of home chefs I
love it I was eating just just muck from
the street before I got married now
sweet little ELISA it makes me blue
apron all the time I love it you choose
chef's designed recipes you can cook
incredible meals in as little as 20
minutes and they're excellent the
recipes are always changing you're not
going to get tired of repeating the same
recipes and they are super quick and
easy recipe options insanely delicious
flavors it offers a range of recipes
that are bursting with flavor check out
this week's menu get your first three
meals free this is my Thanksgiving gift
to you blue apron calm /co ff8 COV fe fe
that is blue apron calm slash cough fa c
OV e fe fe get your first three meals
free blue apron a better way to cook so
much to get to but i love this question
we have to delve into this question
because the left is finally
acknowledging this may the central
conundrum in in their ideology which is
you can have transgenderism or you can
have feminism but you cannot have both
right now at Eastern Michigan University
the school is canceling a performance of
The Vagina Monologues if you you know
I've done a lot of theater in my life so
I'm familiar with this if you're not
familiar it's women who get on stage and
they talk about their vaginas that's the
Vagina Monologues this was a
groundbreaking theater in recent years
they're cancelling this performance why
is it this has long been a favorite
staple of feminist groups on campus they
always do the Vagina Monologues the
reason they're canceling it is because
it's offensive to people because of
course
not all women have vaginas and not all
people who have vaginas or women don't
you know that
of course that's ridiculous but that's
that's what they believe now not all
women have vaginas because some men who
dress like women or who think that
they're women or who very much want to
be women are now calling themselves
women and this erases the category I got
it I feel for this woman Megan Murphy if
you're watching Megan this feminist
writer in Canada you're welcome to come
on the show anytime you want we can talk
about this because it has me siding with
the feminists and that's a rare
occurrence I am sort of choosing that
that new gender ideology or feminism is
a little bit choosing cyanide or arsenic
but if I have to choose I'm going to
choose the feminists because at least
they're sort of talking about women at
least feminists from the old school at
least of the first wave are talking
about women and the feminists in the
1960s and 70s made a deal with the devil
they may specifically they made a deal
with Karl Marx and Friedrich Nietzsche
they made a deal with a relativism with
nihilism with obliterating the category
of gender altogether the reason they did
this it makes perfect sense why they did
this the first way the feminists they
wanted the vote for women they were
suffragettes they wanted certain
political protections certain political
privileges and advantages and economic
advantages okay that's fine
they still acknowledged that men are men
and women are women men and women have
different bodies they have different
virtues in many ways they have different
tendencies often have different goals
have different ways of being just for
one example women tend to be more
moderate than men
Harvey Mansfield writes about this in
his book manliness they tend to be more
moderate than men I can tell you this
because I was at a bachelor party two
weeks ago I know that moderation is not
a particularly manly virtue it's not
something that men are very good at men
tend to be bolder more assertive and
more willing to take risks that that's
why the vast majority of entrepreneurs
are men because they're more willing to
engage in risky behavior that's why the
people who fall off of mountains and go
swimming with sharks or all
tend to be men because they take riskier
behavior that sometimes leads to
needless danger women do not do that as
much
what are some other virtues modesty is
one women are more naturally inclined to
the virtue of modesty this is another
virtue that feminism has tried to cancel
out they've tried to pretend that men
and women have the same attitude towards
sex for instance men are not terribly
modest men if anything are given to a
little boastfulness or a little
aggression and women are modest which is
why men pursue women I really can't stay
baby it's cold outside
the man is pursuing the woman the woman
says oh I really shouldn't but I'd like
to because it's very nice to be here
with you feminists have attacked that
traditionally feminine virtue as well
now they've insisted that women be
promiscuous that women go out and treat
sex just like men do but the trouble is
men like casual sex a lot more than
women do and a lot of what you're seeing
on campus the so called campus rape
epidemic is not so much about rape it's
about consensual relations that maybe
involve a little too much booze or a
little too much of this or that and a
lot of bad ideology so in a lot of these
campus so-called rape hoaxes we've found
out from text messages or emails or
phone calls that very often women will
go back to the man's room they'll
they'll engage in certain sexual acts
that are perfectly consensual and then
the next day they won't regret it
and say this was rape because I didn't
really want to do it or I wish I hadn't
done it or I drank too much or whatever
you want to say the the cause of this
obviously this is not to say that men
should ever feel that they can get
aggressive or if a woman says no that
they should be able to have sex with her
anyway that that is totally that's the
point that feminists want to focus on
that isn't the point the point is that
second wave feminism has made these
women miserable studies show this from
the 1970s all the way to I think the
study goes up to around 2010 we see that
women become much less happy during the
rise of second and third wave feminism
that's true in relative terms that's
true in absolute terms not just relative
to men but absolutely their happiness
has decreased a lot of this has to do
with the denial that men and women are
different and
just as a matter of talking about the
virtues of men and women it seems to me
an insane notion that developed in the
60s and 70s that the only way for women
to be free to be equal to be living
their best lives is to pretend to be
meant to be a worse version of men to be
aggressive to be promiscuous to be what
all of some of the worst characters and
characteristics of men that women would
adopt this seems crazy to me even just
on that question of promiscuity and the
virtue of modesty in it is true there's
a sexual double standard that this has
been true for ever men get away with
more they get away with more casual sex
and women take them back and this isn't
through the other way around the
traditional response of women to this is
to try to get men to stop being such
dogs to stop being such cads but the
response of second wave feminism changed
that flipped it on its head and said
women should be dogs two women are in
any better than men in that regard but
in that regard really they are
traditionally all of this is to say when
you you rode the distinction between men
and women you end up with transgender
ideology that ironically guts feminism
itself
I'm not when I talk about transgenderism
I'm not talking about the handful of
people who are confused
psychologically about their gender they
they're a man he's a man who thinks he's
a woman or he very much wants to be a
woman that we're talking in that case
about 2.2 2.4 percent of the population
at the wildest estimates I'm not talking
about those people I'm talking about the
etiology of transgenderism which is
being foisted on us by leftist activists
which is why 0.2 percent of the
population is dominating the national
conversation about the sex it's because
it's not really about helping those
people at all what it's about is erasing
the difference between men and women
okay fine that's one strategy if they
want to take it they say okay the way
for women to be equal to men is to just
behave like men and pretend that they're
men and to act like men all right if
there's no difference between men and
women as we are told time and time again
there's no difference
the physical differences are minor but
really on a real level there's no
difference then what's a woman the
reason that we have different words for
men and women is because they're
different if men and women are the same
you would only have one word which is
man right you would I Gor woman I guess
but you don't really just just one word
there wouldn't be any difference okay
now few of us would grant that that
there's actually no difference between
men and women even though the ideologues
are trying to tell us this but take that
one step further if there's no
difference between men and women then
why do we have feminism feminism femme
for females but if there's no
distinction between males and females
why have feminism at all what is
feminism it's nothing what this opens
the door to especially the transgender
ideology is a question of who gets to
define what a woman is and this is the
big argument that people like Megan
Murphy the feminist writer is having
with Twitter right now which is Twitter
is taking the side of the transgender
ideology and Megan Murphy is defending
the feminist ideology and what Megan
Murphy is saying is I am a woman I will
define what a woman is men do not get to
define what a woman is and what Twitter
is saying is now what are you told
there's no definition of when men and
women know it's how dare you how hateful
of you but just think of the transgender
ideology one of its expressions is
transvestitism crossdressers drag queens
you go to drag bars would you say that a
drag queen and I'm from New York so
they're a drag bars all over the village
you know you see this a fair bit would
you say that a drag queen is a woman
that that's what a woman is no of course
not that's one fantasy version of a
woman that's a caricature or a cartoon
of a woman big eyelashes crazy hair wild
outfits big lipstick and everything
that's that's a cartoon of a woman but
that's not a woman and feminists have
been telling us for years they're saying
how dare you doll us up and force us to
wear makeup and high heels and
big eyelashes that's not what a woman is
a woman can be anything this is the
snake eating its own tail this is the
natural logical conclusion of second way
of feminism the the feminists like Megan
Murphy are upset about this now
because obviously it's undercutting
their entire ideology but this is not
some random turn of events that swooped
in and tried to undermine feminism
though the roots of feminism's being
undermined is in the ideology itself you
have to decide are men and women
different or are men and women exactly
the same or the sexes complementary or
are the sexes indiscernible identical
exactly without any distinction between
them reasonable people for all of
history and including right now all
reasonable people will have to conclude
men and women are different are
complementary this is true biologically
this is true spiritually this is true
psychologically this is simply traits
true socially they're complimentary and
different they are not exactly the same
but this raises many more difficult
questions for the left because if men
and women really are different if there
is a difference between the sexes then
what are we to make of the courts
redefining marriage the court has
redefined marriage to include monogamous
same-sex unions but not polygamous
same-sex unions not polygamous different
sex unions why is that because the
premise not the debate over whether we
should expand the definition of marriage
but the premise of just doing it by
judicial Fiat is that sexual difference
doesn't matter to marriage it doesn't
really matter that much at all but the
question is what is marriage does sexual
difference have something to do with
marriage it has for all of history in
every single society ever now we are on
an experiment of the gender neutral
society we're trying to see if if we can
erase sexual distinctions not just from
marriage but from bathrooms from
occupations from battle from athletics
can we can we erase them and I suppose
we can we're doing it we're plotting
along but is that good is that good for
women is that good for men is it good
for society is it real I'm not so sure
about that
if we conclude that men and women are
different I think it's very hard to look
through history and culture and just our
own experience of the world and pretend
that sexual difference doesn't have
something to do with marriage
for instance or that sexual difference
doesn't have something to do with
athletics you know now
Millennials are shocked when they find
out that Serena Williams can't beat
professional male tennis players
remember there was that big hubbub a
while ago Serena Williams the Williams
sisters were insisting that they could
beat male tennis players and this became
of course they could their wonderful
tennis players but they can't they can't
at all they tried this in 1998 at the
Australian Open they said that they
would be able to beat any male tennis
player ranked outside of the top 200 so
the guy who was ranked number two or
three Carsten barash decided he would
play both of them in the same day and
see if they could beat him he he
prepared for his matches by playing a
round of golf drinking a couple of beers
and smoking a few cigarettes he beat one
of the Williams sisters six to two and
the other one six to one he handily beat
of course I'm not making fun of the
Williams sisters or female athletes I'm
saying that male athletes and female
athletes are different and men
physically are stronger than women this
is an a fact of biology and a fact of
nature we're trying to pretend that that
isn't true we're seeing this now in
certain combat positions among soldiers
we're seeing this in in other athletics
as well there was that woman Tameka
Brent's I believe a female UFC fighter
who decided she was going to fight
a transgender which means male fighter
someone named Fallon Fox so they went
into the ring Tamika Brent's is a great
athlete she got her skull crushed she
got her skull cracked open by this guy
she said she'd never felt more
overpowered in her life of course men
are physically stronger this is why in
our culture men don't hit women like
Michael avenatti allegedly where you're
not supposed to hit women why would we
not hit women if men and women are
exactly the same if men and women are
exactly the same there's no difference
then there's no reason to treat women in
some special way but of course men and
women are different we should treat them
in a special way we've been grappling
with this problem for a long time
conservatives have been pushing and this
discussing this for a long time we
haven't let up on it even in the wake of
second wave and third wave feminism
transgenderism brings this issue to the
bear because it's no longer just
theoretical it's no longer just a
question of well you know perhaps in
some hypothetical world men and women
are the same no men are now pretending
to be women they're demanding that they
use the changing rooms with little girls
they're the demanding that bathrooms
have genders erased from them that there
are all gender bathrooms and even that
deconstruction of male and female is
leading to the deconstruction of gender
categories altogether Facebook has 56
gender categories where they had 56
gender categories and now they have an
unlimited number 56 was too restrictive
so you have to ask the people how many
genders are there what is a gender if
we're told that the genders are all the
same then why why have well I have to
why have 56 why have any they're all the
same they're all the same and they're
all different it's it's a total
destruction of these narratives that
have been building for a long time we
should celebrate this because we're
correcting a lot of errors that have
been in our culture for 50 60 years at
this point but both sides have to be
honest here and it's fun to watch
various factions of the left battle with
each other it's like the iran-iraq war
you want you somehow want them both to
lose your joy you're all you're hoping
for is a pro longing of the battle but I
we hope that they come out on the right
side here we have to make sure because
as this woman is finding out Megan
Murphy she is being silenced for saying
that men are not women she's being
silenced for stating the premise of
feminism I I hope that this opens her
eyes also to the kind of censorship that
conservatives face on a daily basis on
these platforms and perhaps we'll end up
with a feminist conservative alliance
against this absurd gender ideology but
it's going to mean that feminists have
to come to the table that they have to
stop insisting that the personal
the political that they have to deal
with an alliance with people that they
might not agree with on a number of
other issues I think it's just delicious
I think it's a little Thanksgiving treat
I'm excited
feminists watching this show come on
come on over the water is warm can't
wait to have you on we'd love to have
you on the show to talk about it we have
a lot more that we have to talk about
too though so Thanksgiving is coming up
this is very exciting I'm about to get
out of here I'm gonna fly out on the
red-eye tonight I'm going out with my
in-laws it's gonna be a lot of fun right
now oh you know gosh before we get to it
I do I wonder too it just occurred to me
if if we're having this battle now
between the feminists and the
transgender what what will happen about
other conflicts within the left there
are other conflicts within the left
central ideological conflicts one that
comes to mind are the people who are
vegan but pro-abortion you know a lot of
people like this they say oh gosh I love
the little the cute little chicken I
could never eat the chase a cute little
chicken oh that baby kill it give that
human baby that's going to become a
person with consciousness and and
thoughts and an appreciation of beauty
and love kill that thing but the chicken
but the little but the delta smelt I
love the Delta smell oh yeah watch that
stop stop talking to me about the baby
get the baby out of here
that of course is impossible you can't
coherent labia a vegetarian or a vegan
and in favor of abortion but but the
left does it I don't know what will
force them to deal with that issue
perhaps sonograms or something but it's
the same with Islam and Western
liberalism you have that same conflict
to Western left-wingers Western liberals
have embraced Islam because they want to
be open-minded they want to be
religiously tolerant and also they don't
really like Western culture and the West
and the Islamic world have been engaged
in attention since the 7th century but
what happens when you invite in this
Islamist ideology which undermines all
of Western liberalism which undermines
religious tolerance itself GK Chesterton
said there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped
will the left understand that tension
that essential conflict there's so many
others we could talk about them all day
we don't have time because Thanksgivings
coming up but
food for thought if we can get them to
reconsider their feminist premises
what other premises will the left have
to reconsider we're living in the best
timeline I tell you this all the time on
Thanksgiving the University of Oregon is
hosting an event called thanks but no
thanks giving
they hate Thanksgiving why is that they
call it decolonizing an American holiday
the the description of the event the
main messages of Thanksgiving are that
of gratitude food and family
however Thanksgiving is foundationally
speaking a celebration of the ongoing
genocide against native peoples and
cultures across the globe you knew that
right that's what you do you go to your
Thanksgiving table you sit down oh it's
so nice to see you auntie May all right
well let's raise a glass to the ongoing
genocide of native peoples all around
the globe
let's chin chin huzzah salon shut no I
don't think so that's not what happens
it's just not true this is what happens
when an entire generation is deprived of
an historical education and instead that
historical education is replaced with
ideology the pilgrims did not commit any
genocide against the Native Americans it
did not happen in fact the opposite
happened the real story is much more
interesting Christopher Columbus did not
committed genocide against the native
peoples he adopted his Indian friend's
son is what he did he didn't commit any
genocide he just simply didn't happen so
from a historical standpoint their main
premise is bunk
the real story there was so much more
interesting I have four ancestors who
were on the Mayflower
I had one was a pilgrim dr. Samuel
fuller the other three were derelicts
they were strangers you know half the
Mayflower were these pilgrims who were
godly men religious separatists wanted
to start their own religious commune and
the other half were just guys who wanted
to go into the new world so three of the
four were those guys one of them 11
years before the mayflower sailed
Stephen Hopkins was actually shipwrecked
in the new world and that shipwreck was
the basis of Shakespeare's The Tempest
he was a mutineer another one of my
Gregory grandfather's John Billington
was the first man in America executed
for murder the other Francis Eaton was
another mutineer another troublemaker
so those three kind of shady fellows but
one of them was
good in a godly man dr. Samuel fuller
and so they came over the story of them
arriving is a miracle it is sure
Providence there is no other way to
explain it they were separatists living
in England they then moved to Leiden in
the Netherlands because they wanted to
escape persecution they were there for
about a decade and they started to get a
little nervous though because their
children became a little too Dutch they
didn't like how Dutch their kids were
becoming so they decided they're gonna
sail for the new world start their new
their new community okay they hire a
captain they hire a cruise and
everything but because of the religious
tension between them if King James
between them in the Church of England
there there were there was an attempted
sabotage to stop the the ships from
sailing out this delayed them by months
they finally make it out of England but
they're many months late they sail
across and they veer way off course they
were headed for Manhattan they ended up
around Cape Cod so they had no land
grant to that area they land there it's
not nearly as hospitable as Manhattan
was they land and they they couldn't
find a good place to to park the boat so
but they get out there looking around
they immediately are approached by a
group of thirty Indians who start
hurling arrows at them and miraculously
none of them was hurt none of them had
even a scratch on them after this
encounter they're wandering around they
finally end up at Plymouth Plymouth
Harbor they pull into Plymouth and they
find fields that are totally cleared
they're cleared for agriculture but
there are no people there there they're
just clear white whitened bones because
an epidemic had taken place just within
a couple of years before the Pilgrims
landed and they cleared the field they
found a bushel of corn that it was just
waiting for them there and they also
found arrowheads they found some weapons
that they could use against any
potential hostile natives what the
pilgrims did is they took the corn so
one of their first acts in the new world
was an act of theft but they wouldn't
take the arrowheads they wouldn't
disturb what was a gravesite they felt
it would be very wrong to disturb what
had become a religious gravesite for
them so there
this oldest act also have respect toward
the natives they're there for about two
months and out of the woods walks a
naked Indian naked as the day he was
born Samoset who says in in English
welcome Englishman they somehow stumbled
on one of two natives in the Western
Hemisphere who spoke English and Samoset
wasn't even supposed to be there he was
just he was from Maine and he just
happened to be visiting down by Plymouth
down where the Pilgrims landed at
exactly the time that they accidentally
landed there he says welcome Englishman
it gets weirder because he then brings
them Squanto who speaks virtually
perfect English Squanto was at that time
a hostage of the Pokanoket sachem Massa
suet and he was brought there to
communicate between the natives and the
English he also just happened to be
walking down he spoke perfect English
because he lived in Spain and London he
was captured by Thomas Hunt in English
sailor years earlier brought to Spain
worked there as a slave he somehow makes
it to England we don't know how one
story is that Catholic monks smuggled
him over we don't really really don't
know he's talking to the Englishmen
about the streets of London can you
imagine the feeling that the pilgrims
must have had he he then is brought
because of a kindly Englishman back to
the new world he wanders down to to
Plymouth and is then held hostage by
Massa suet just at the time that the
pilgrims accidentally arrived there or
providentially arrived there which seems
obviously to be the case so they make it
there and they negotiate a peace between
the natives and the pilgrims this was
not taking advantage of the natives I
think the left now what they want to
pretend is that the natives are these
idiots they're these imbeciles who can't
possibly talk to the advanced Englishmen
and they don't know anything about
politics or war or statecraft
or there that's absurd that's so
disrespectful to the natives masses so
it was a serious man he forged an
alliance with the pilgrims it helped him
essentially found the Wampanoag nation
to greatly expand his power as the head
of the Wampanoag nation and he helped
out the pilgrims the pilgrims saved his
life one day Massa so was on the verge
of death Edward Winslow
a pilgrim cleared out his mouth gave him
a little medicine brought him back to
life he then told the pilgrims that the
Massachusetts tribe I think led by
Elizabeth Warren was going to attack
them they were able to join together and
both and repel them this was an
incredible Alliance they embraced
Christianity the natives largely they
took on Christian names NASA so it's
children were named Alexander and Philip
they had Christian names Alexander
remained a good friend of the pilgrims
until he died unfortunately while he was
being interrogated by the pilgrims and
his brother King Philip blamed the
pilgrims for his death there's no
evidence that the pilgrims killed him
but that means that within 20 to 30
years after the Pilgrims landed that
wonderful alliance which benefited both
of them had broken down because King
Philip was a terrible leader and made a
mistake in his interpretation of the
events and destroyed the whole region he
started a war that killed a lot a lot of
natives and ultimately broke down that
relationship that's the real story
that's a very different story than what
the left wants to foist on you it's a
much more interesting story - it gives
much more respect to the natives and it
gives a lot more respect to our
ancestors to whom we should be very
grateful to whom we should give
Thanksgiving we are standing on their
shoulders in this greatest country ever
in the history of the world and we are
spitting on our ancestors because we
want to judge them not only from our
leisurely position in history and from
our dubious moral stances in our present
time in 2018 but also based on history
that is total bunk you can bring that
one up at your Thanksgiving table we got
a lot more to get to we got to get to
the mailbag today so first if you're on
daily wire.com thank you very much you
keep the lights on you keep Kofi Fay in
my cup that's very important it's ten
bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you have to ask questions in the mailbag
which is coming up right now most
importantly the leftist here's tumblr if
you I don't recommend that you prod your
left-wing relatives at the Thanksgiving
table don't do if they bring something
up answer it but don't prod them but if
they bring it up and you've got to talk
to them about how incredible this
ministration has been how great the
country is going peace abroad tax reform
justice Kavanagh I'm getting all excited
you're gonna need this or you're gonna
get flooded right out of your living
room right out of your dining room
hopefully maybe you can try to grab onto
the dining room table like your rose and
the Titanic but this is the safer option
collect the leftist tears in the only
fda-approved vessel for them the leftist
tears tumbler and we'll be right back
from Ryan is the right to vote a
positive right or a negative right this
question was asked yesterday during the
conversation but you sort of drifted
into another albeit informative tangent
and never actually answered I do that
sometimes the answer is voting is a
positive right I'm sorry I got very
taken by your question I remember
yesterday during the conversation a
negative right is a right to be left
alone it's your right to life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness it's a
right that doesn't require anything from
anybody else other than they are
respecting that right a positive right
is something that does require somebody
else so health care is a positive right
if we have a political right to health
care it is a positive right because it
requires certain technology certain
advancements certain buildings certain
people's labour money productivity so
that's a positive right
voting is a positive right it is
established in our country it's run by
the states so you need States to run it
you need voting machines to process the
votes you need poll workers to check
people in you need poll security to make
sure that people aren't violating the
laws when it comes to elections you need
people to count the ballots you need
people to certify the ballots you need a
lot of people so it's a positive right
it's a good right that we have in this
country I'm not saying that all positive
rights are bad in any way governments do
create positive rights and they need
money and they need participation to
ensure those but it's not a negative
right and we talked about as
conservatives how important negative
rights are life liberty the pursuit of
happiness
that's true but we interact with
positive rights every day and that's a
wonderful thing from Nathan deplorable
Noel's a leftist asked when I thought
the child became a human life and I said
when it's got its own DNA at conception
he said sperm and ovaries have their own
DNA and it must be a crime every time a
woman ovulates without giving birth or
manage a queue laits any counter to this
argument would be helpful thanks Nathan
I think the human child becomes a human
around 18 years old maybe maybe 22 I
don't know maybe know the traditional
answer and the correct answer is at the
point of conception
absolutely right human beings have 46
chromosomes in their DNA the sperm and
the egg each have 23 chromosomes and
that's when the sperm and the egg come
together you get a human being which is
46 chromosomes you're making the
argument from DNA fair enough I think
that's a perfectly fine argument but
that's why that's why it's different you
know this the sperm left alone will
never become a human adult it doesn't
have the DNA for it and it won't happen
same thing with the egg but brought
together at the point of conception that
that new human life will develop when
does the human life begin we know that
at the point of conception the it is
living that that created entity that
begotten entity is living and we know
that it's human it's not a duck it's not
a platypus it's not a sperm it's not an
egg it's a human being it's it's what we
would call a human just as a matter of
language to conception is the beginning
when the thing is conceived when it is
begotten when it is initiated it that is
the beginning of it by definition and
the question for your friend I guess is
when else would be the beginning of that
human life we know it's human at that
point and not before we know that it's
living at that point and not before when
else would the human life be a human
life three weeks later why because it
grows fingernails or something is that
don't do fingernails make us you know of
course not a human life becomes a human
life at the beginning when it becomes a
human life from Jared dear patron saint
of the Kofi fades my wife and I are
starting to argue more just because it
is difficult to clean my left is tears
tumblr every time that we attempt to
clean it it just fills up again
especially after the recent DeSantis and
Scott wins in Florida as well as Mia
love pulling ahead in our state of Utah
how can we attempt to clean the tumblr
out if it just keeps on filling you got
to drink faster it's the only way that
you can do it I can't do this for you I
can't give you some magical device to
desalinate you're a leftist here's to
you just have to drink faster
if you're not drinking fast or you do
you love your country do you love
watching the left implode
I don't know I'm beginning to question
them guzzle guzzle especially on
Thanksgiving Day leave leave a little
room leave a little room for pumpkin pie
and leave extra room for left two steers
for max dear Michael what do you think
about the metric system should it be
introduced in the United States thanks
for the show you're just trolling me
aren't you is that what this is about
I think the metric system is the soccer
of measurements that's what I think it
is it's absolutely unamerican it's
horrific it's too rational is the
problem that's why that's the thing I
dislike the most about the metric system
it's - oh it's a it's based on units of
ten and you've got the millah and the
center and the Desa okay well that's
fine too rational life isn't that
rational life isn't that clean it's not
that clinical how many inches in a foot
twelve why I don't know couldn't tell
you how many feet in a yard three why I
don't know couldn't tell you that's why
because it's American damn it because
we're in the West because we've done it
for years and years because that's our
tradition it's built into our
institutions it's built into our culture
and I'll be damned if you're gonna
replace it with some French nonsense
they did this in the French Revolution
after the French Revolution they took
away everything that was beautiful and
traditional about that culture and they
just divided the country up into
quadrants and neighborhoods along these
perfectly rigid lines and it just was
disgusting it's to clinical it's to
rational one point I will make too about
the English system the standard system
of measurement is it's got these really
nice numbers in there 3 3 feet in the
yard like the Trinity like the Holy
Trinity is a very important number 12
inches in a foot 12 apostles one plus
two is three that's a that's a beautiful
I like this so this is very nice
there's something that it speaks to
something deeper than just a cold
French rationality French French
irrationality of the metric system get
it out of here no way if it comes into
the United States I'm moving to Canada
except they have the metric system -
damn it that's not good that's very
maybe I'll move to England
no no they use it sometimes - oh that's
very tough where am I to go this is the
last best hope of man on earth if the
metric system comes here there's nowhere
left to escape so we have to defend
standard measurements from Peter do
best book writer ever Knowles what do
you think it will take for the United
States to have a second civil war love
the show thanks Peter
it would take people getting off their
couch people lifting up their eyes from
their smartphones for two second and not
taking selfies constantly this is what
I'm not that worried about the Civil War
I know some people are we're in a
cultural Cold War if you want to use
that language I know Dennis Prager uses
that language some other people do we we
do seem to be very angry with one
another culturally there's not much
bridging that gap but that's all tweets
I'm not worried about tweets tweets
can't shoot me we use these terms war we
bandy them about attack so we bandy them
about Dan Crenshaw congressman Dan
Crenshaw made this great point on Face
the Nation the other day some lefty
lunatic on Face the Nation was saying
Donald Trump is attacking our freedoms
he's attacking his attacking Dan
Crenshaw said listen I've been attacked
this is my wound from my attack let's
use our words precisely because when we
tweet that's not an attack that's not
what that is I don't think we're moving
toward a civil war who would have the
the stamina to fight the civil war to
say nothing of the fact that only
conservatives have guns in this country
more or less so I don't think the civil
war would last very long I think we've
got relative peace for the time being
we've got to put down these little ant
Aoife thugs of course but more or less I
think we're doing just fine something to
be thankful for this Thanksgiving from
Marc dear Michael if we make it easier
to voluntarily commit insane people in
order to protect the public from them
don't you have an inherent fear that the
left will use that as a tool against
anyone who happens to own guns because a
gun owners are pretty much insane people
to them
sidenote I mean seriously you should
have seen the faces on my colleagues
over here on the East Coast when I told
them my two-year-old son loves to help
me load nerf guns I said I'd rather have
him be comfortable with guns and know
about them than to always be in fear of
them their faces were priceless you make
a good point the story illustrates that
the left doesn't understand guns they
would try to commit gun owners right we
need to be able to make it easier to
involuntarily commit people because
we've got lunatics who are hurting
themselves who are hurting society who
are shooting people who are committing
all sorts of violent acts but it doesn't
necessarily mean that that some
government agent
be able to come in and lift you out of
your home and throw you into the loony
bin perhaps though your family should be
able to do it more easily perhaps
relatives of yours your spouse your
maybe close friends should be able to do
it a little bit more easily there it
doesn't have to be
Big Brother government comes in on the
helicopter and lifts you out of your
life or we allow crazy people to live on
the street and squalor
hurting themselves hurting society and
posing a danger to society there is some
middle ground this I know this irritates
libertarians sometimes but we need to be
able to deal seriously with these
problems that are not accounted for in
their ideologies we need to be able to
account for people who cannot take care
of themselves who are mentally unfit to
behave in society and who pose a danger
we've got to be able perhaps most
importantly to protect society from them
this has been true in virtually every
Society in history this was true in the
United States until just a few decades
ago and we we need to return to that the
reason that we let the lunatics out of
the asylums is because of the
development of psychiatric drugs so you
would take the drugs and many of your
symptoms would be cured this is good you
no longer have to lock them up
the trouble was that when people got out
they would stop taking the drugs and
this would pose a threat to society to
themselves and make them live in squalor
if we can make them take the drugs and
ensure that they'll keep taking the
drugs that's fine to let them be on the
street and be or in their own homes or
wherever behave in a way that is
conducive with civilized society if not
you got to pin them off because they
pose a threat from Peter millennial
Knolls I was raised Catholic went to a
Catholic school but have been an atheist
most of my life recently I've been
attending Protestant churches with my
girlfriend I've learned much more about
the Bible in Protestant churches than I
did from Catholic school in church
Protestant churches seem to have an
hour-long homily and little Sacrament
Catholic Mass is the opposite my
experience can that change should that
change I've noticed this too in certain
Protestant churches which is that
especially evangelical Southern Baptists
you get this a little bit they just or
can be excellent exegetes of the Bible
sometimes they're very poor exegetes of
the Bible the trouble with an hour-long
homily is sometimes it can be
illuminating life-changing spiritual and
sometimes it can be drivel it can be
auntie
biblical anti-christian heresy the
trouble is and depends upon who is
giving the homily this is a major
difference though I like that I love
Bible studies I love exegesis I like
reading theologians some Protestant
theologians as well but I don't go to
church for a Bible study I go to Bible
study for Bible study I read my Bible
from Bible I read books about the Bible
for Bible study I go to church to
worship God to engage in the sacraments
Christ came down
he's the divine logic of the universe
and he became incarnate the only
begotten son of God who is God became
incarnate and talked to men and touched
them and rub mud on their eyes and spoke
to them and had a body and in my view at
least in the Catholic view he founded a
church and he left us sacraments he says
do this in memory of me
this is this bread is my body which will
be given up for you
this wine is my blood which will be
given up for you this bread is my real
body you have to eat the flesh of the
Son of Man my flesh is real food this is
a hard saying he harps on this he might
say he makes this a very serious point
of saying this is real food you have to
engage in a real sacrament in in the
real combination the real meeting of the
metaphysical and the physical the
metaphor in the literal and that's what
happens in Catholic churches that's what
happens in certain Protestant churches
Church of England anglo-catholic this is
what happens in Eastern Orthodoxy and so
that's what I go there for I go there to
worship God sometimes I get a good
homily very often I get a not-so-great
homily and maybe I'll listen to somebody
else's homily on the ride home I'm glad
that you're learning more about the
Bible and getting good exegesis but you
might ask yourself what else should I be
getting should I be getting sacraments
should I be eating the flesh of the Son
of Man should I be worshipping God in a
way that it's not just edifying for me
and my knowledge of the Bible but which
is giving praise to the creator of the
universe and giving thanks which we'll
do on Thanksgiving that's our show have
a very good Thanksgiving everybody I
hope you survive all of the traffic and
the dinner table discussions of politics
I will see you back on Monday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018